if you look at the stats on what happens
post 2014 when social media really takes
off yeah this is a disease of social
media this idea that there's an infinite
number of genders because in the
disembodied online world you can say
that right so the more we go into living
online the easier it is to believe
things that aren't true because there's
no hard test like if I pick up this
bottle of water and let it go we know
what's going to happen because it
happens in the real world so I think the
part of this is It's a disease of social
media and then we've also got to
position and J height writes about this
in the cuddling of the American mind
where we've created successive
generations of people who've not been
brought up properly and victimhood is
now currency right again this is an
online phenomenon you know I'm a first
generation immigrant in the UK okay a
dark skin if I say well you know people
have been racist to me which they have
right therefore here's some things that
are true people are much more likely to
listen to that even though there's no
reason to actually take it that my
opinion any more seriously than anybody
else's